proposez-leur face à l'insécurité
galopante
c'est vrai qu'on n'est bonne versées par
les faits divers d'une violence inouïe
qui se sont produits récemment je pense
au triple homicide de danger pour ne
citer que lui ou ce médecin militaire
égorgée dans ses enfants enfin et puis
la sécurité du quotidien les vols les
agressions
[Musique]
voilà toutes sortes de délits ou de
crimes
dont notre pays a je crois aujourd'hui
une nécessité absolue de combattre alors
sur l'insécurité on a des propositions
j'évoquais tout à l'heure le recrutement
dans la justice comme le disait un de
nos collègues le problème de la police
et la justice siècle la justice n'a pas
les moyens d'instruire aussi rapidement
et efficacement qu'elle le devrait et en
dépit de tous les efforts de nos forces
de sécurité qu'il nous faut protéger
des agressions dont ils sont l'objet
bien il faut pouvoir recruter dans le
dans le domaine de la justice et nous
avons fait des propositions pour que
tous ceux qui portent l'uniforme qu'ils
sont là pour nous défendre lorsqu'ils
sont attaqués et bien que les auteurs de
ces agressions fasse l'objet d'une
sévérité
particulière parce qu'il s'attaque à
ceux qui nous défendre et nous protège
les peines planchers la construction de
places de prison des moyens
supplémentaires pour les forces de
l'ordre et de la justice la suspension
des allocations familiales n'ont pas la
suppression la suspension ce qui est une
différence notable pour les parents
parce que les parents tu ne parles
responsabilités et des parents qui
démissionne face à la délinquance de
leurs enfants et il faut pouvoir
évidemment lorsqu'il ya une défaillance
éducatif pouvoir le dire le signifié
très clairement et puis il faut lutter
contre les squats en expulsant
automatiquement voilà quelques mesures
que nous avons que nous préconisons mais
il est clair que la question la question
de la de la sécurité les devenu elle est
devenue majeure